try to feel where your weight is on
where his energy is so we already know
that I feel his feet through here okay
and so I'm going to go where this is
effortless how close I
am where where do I that's strong you
see I got to go around that part I got
to go around that part
so past the part and around the
part I have to go past this heavy
part and I have to go round the sword I
do that by using the curve of my
weapon and I put my body where that is
where it just drops my body is here I'm
back here it's not so weighted over
there
okay I'm just feeling
where's the in space that's what I want
where's the in
space I'm not over here turning my hand
I'm not trying to do it
by pushing his
weapon just go
around if you watch my
grid it it can be pretty loose it'll do
it I just hold the sword but I'm not
moving the sword I hold the sword
then say now now i' I've not contested
his
weapon now I'm going to
sink let that let the Y sink on okay I
add that
here so so you're releasing drills that
you do I just release into this okay
I'm not I'm not trying to do anything
extra doing it progressively so the
first one is non contest second one is
release
okay non
contest
release just doing it together
okay try
it and now I I connect my tip to the to
that sinking sheet my tip I unite with
this still same
okay say heavy on that side not just not
just me sinking here here that it was
light on the last progression but here I
connect the tip to that okay it's like
he's trying to lift my hat right I I can
sink this but now I'm going to connected
the che to it so same exact thing
here on the okay all right let's try it
okay now we'll give it some tactical
purpose so the Tactical purpose is that
I'm going to drop
this hit the
hands and contact through the center and
into the
legs
okay so I don't want to just pull on his
shoulders I don't want to pull on his
should
shoulders this thing has to go into his
body same exact
thing try
okay so he's doing that at at one level
okay and what makes it work is that I
stay here and then that thing's going to
do everything it just did okay so we're
going to work on
neutralizing that okay so as he goes
around you'll feel the negative you so
when we go here I felt his feet and now
as he goes around oh everything got
light okay got it so I don't wait until
it gets heavy again to start reacting I
react on the yin so as he goes around
then I can make that start working that
on me
okay right when I feel it goes light and
then I just work it right back on there
but pay attention you I
still it won't work okay so once I feel
him lightning I stick with
it and follow back his light let
is
okay so we'll go slow so everyone can be
sensitive because what happens is if you
go like half F right no no no like like
we were before you go a little quicker
see then a goes like that but it was
heavy and that in full speed I wouldn't
have been able to do that okay so I
don't want you to go so fast that you
have to externally do it I want you to
feel where it's going to just float
right into
place okay
and again I'm showing you I don't need
my grip to do this it just floats right
into place but do keep your grip okay
you keep your
grip okay let's
try all right so the same thing as he
goes right and I lay this here this is
right going to just sink and release
Within Me
everything's
relax okay TR okay and now you connect
the tip to that to that sinking
so the
tip tip
tip okay let's try okay and now we aim
back we have the same thing where we're
going to aim we we're going to hit the
hands but we're going to aim into that
okay we gave it a tactical
[Music]
purpose as I get this you're going to
see that I'm going to
go less
backwards and less curvy okay I'm
why so
I my absorption is in in my Bas my
absorptions in my base there no
different he pushes I absorb in my base
and I don't have to
go it's just in the
B same thing here he's trying to do his
m
and absorb in the base in the
base in the
base once I've cleared it's clear you
see I start attacking
okay let's
try so we do the
[Music]
same
AB you can turn if you
[Music]
want
absorb turn
right not
here okay there's an
absorption in the
projection the absortion and the
projection straight
straight okay it here back out here back
out but we're not going to let you do
the feet okay you can only shift your
weight front to back
right so I'm strong enough to eventually
I'll get her okay and and probably under
normal circumstances you you would have
stepped and absorbed or to where she hit
that softness where my sword can go
around it do you get it so here what you
got to go slow I'm going to talk first
is I I'll absorb this
externally and then I'll do the rest
internally until it all goes off you see
and then that's when I that's what I
would project
as opposed to it better happen here do
you get it so it's just here and then
very
light till it goes
off example here I could hear it he but
I take it light and then she's light
internal
external internal external internal
external
absorb till she goes
off all right till she goes off and it
comes back and it goes off off and it
goes back off
okay more energetically than spatially
okay when yours move they should move
like this there's nothing there's
nothing on the on the house okay but
they don't go around energy too they
don't go around his energy okay but they
don't go like
this okay so it's inside and Mard is
right outside
in light
out okay
so this is for you Virginia in light
out in light out okay and then you don't
go too much
around where you feel feel her that's
where
you there are
here I'm going
over I stay
in in
[Music]
that still go into your body
my hand move this
way they don't go
over
over even if I start don't go stay with
her
do part way get heavy to see part way
and then project
St so that he's heavy I go here take
some off
project from off
okay little bit
more so you're letting your hands
go you move your hands stop at any point
you want look do you see okay you're
going like this what I'm doing is you
push my hands you understand yes
wherever you you push my
hands see let them push your so I let
you grip and then push my hand so if you
you like that one but you push my hands
it's not me getting out of the way you
push my hands that's what I'm that's
what
I I might give you angle you
see okay I shifted your here but you
push my hand you push my hand and then I
push
it I might want half
you
push
I my body
back you
push you push why let you push me front
foot back foot
but you push me I
don't you
push
you you
push you
push okay trying to never conf that
you're moving you're you're getting out
of his way you see that that's not uh iy
that's not communion that's still the
contesting mind as as I am getting out
of the way of him you see that so I
don't want to do that I let him touch
you see let him
touch I can't let him
push you
see but I don't you don't have
to okay because I have the internal
option about how much I let pass through
me okay so even if as you see me do this
kind of stuff it's not that I'm going
like I let him touch I move me out of
the
way touch move me
out can't do it very small
you you should you should be getting
smaller
smaller but you get it cuz we're doing
that you're doing your fighting you're
doing your Technique mix internal and
external but you're doing these kind of
drills very
small you want to be very small
even
immediate play with your
feet test yourself
right change directions even right
especially if you're with twist
we don't usually do that in
ik but there's no reason if I'm project
if I'm projecting you sag across the M
there's no reason why we can't do
[Music]
this you
can you can do
that okay it's very possible especially
when you're with r
interested okay all right
e
e e